حَبِيبَةُ أُمِّهُاَ  مِنْ قَلْبِى أُحِبُّهَا
مَنْ تُسْعِدُ أُمَّهَا  مَنْ تُسْعِدُ أُمَّهَا
نُصَفِّقْ ..نُهَلِّلْ  فَرَحَاً مِنْ أَجْلِهَا
حَبِيبَةُ أُمِّهُاَ  مِنْ قَلْبِى أُحِبُّهَا
أَحْلَى البَنَات الحُلْوَةْ مَنْ تَجْلِسْ هَادِئَةْ
مَنْ تُعْطِى مَامَا قُبْلَةْ  لِتَغْدُو هَانِئَةْ
هِيَ أَجْمَلُ بِنْتٍ قُدْوَةْ  وَالكُلُّ يُحِبُّهَا
تُعَاوِنُ دُونَ ضَجَرٍ  بِالمَنْزِلِ أَهْلَهَا
مِنْ قَلْبِى ...مِنْ قَلْبِى  مِنْ قَلْبِى أُحِبُهَا
مَنْ تُسْعِدُ أُمَّهَا
مِنْ قَلْبِى أُحِبُهَا مَنْ تُسْعِدُ أُمَّهَا
حَبِيبَتِى الرَّقِيِقَةْ  لَطِيفَة مُهَذَّبَةْ
تُصْغِى لِقَوْلِ مَامَا  دَوْمًا وَمُرَتَّبَةْ
لاَ تُزْعِج وَالدِيْهَا  بِالحُبِّ تُطِيعُهُمْ
لَا تَكْذِب مَهْمَا كَانَ تَعْتَذِرُ لِخَطَئِهَا
مِنْ قَلْبِى ...مِنْ قَلْبِى  مِنْ قَلْبِى أُحِبُهَا
مَنْ تُسْعِدُ أُمَّهَا من قلبى أُحِبُهَا
مَنْ تُسْعِدُ أُمَّهَا
تُذَاكِرُ بِاجْتِهَادٍ  وَتُنْجِزُ فَرْضَهَا
وَغَايَتُهَا التَّفَوُّق لِتُحَقِّقَ حُلْمَهَا
حَبِيبَتِى بِعَزْمٍ  سَتُصْبِحُ مَا تُرِيد
وَتَبْلُغُ الأماني  بِعُمْرِهَا السَّعِيدْ
مِنْ قَلْبِى ...مِنْ قَلْبِى  مِنْ قَلْبِى أُحِبُهَا
مَنْ تُسْعِدُ أُمَّهَا
من قلبى أُحِبُهَا مَنْ تُسْعِدُ أُمَّهَا